welcome to this video and begins in
doral enter now let's return to e4 e5
still have not to really looked at some
great line in the way but it's not
mattering much that you got a scotch
game okay yeah my bishop before and
check pet line yeah 93 black can just
play Knight f6 which is objectively the
best move but Queenie 7sm quite often
irritating why players because the e4
pawn is pretty difficult to defend yeah
it can do something like that but Knight
f6 is pretty good now I think and this
is renewing this idea okay hmm let's see
probably with the beep on to have d5
still available and again it's not so
easy for him to protect this I'm also
threatening Queen takes you four so it
move like Bishop g5 is kind of pointless
yeah ok so now i can play d5 and try to
win this Bishop takes Bishop chicks mmm
okay this is actually possible Bishop
takes Bishop takes Knight e-form Bishop
g7 Jenna it's not
it's not entirely clear actually no g3
check my rook is hanging as well Wendy
five is just simple and good move so I'm
going to do that he's now giving it up
only form or has to play the very ugly
move f3 that's probably right him you
don't want to play a three okay against
de for he has got no no he gets got 94
okay so taking and taking with the pawn
is probably the way to win this to win a
pawn yeah Bishop takes and then I mean
okay even my cheeks as possible oh that
is a move I overlooked completely uh-huh
yeah Quincy six Quincy six is the threat
that's very awkward actually hmm very
awkward yeah I can't have to cancel all
that's not much else but now I'm of
course is Bishop takes his three was
wasn't great my dark squares are
completely wrecked huh okay yeah quit
III was strong I completely disregarded
that move that didn't very miss so much
but okay I overlooked stuff earlier in
the game it's this like winces 6 we
should be sick that's not a big issue i
think at least in comparison and where
is he going I'm threatening f2 and so on
so he almost has to take this no he
didn't okay he tries to maybe trap this
night but I can't take them I could just
take the bishop if everything else fails
hmm
that's that's one of those keep it
simple moves I'm getting in c5 so I'm
not blocked here on the dark squares
that's important maybe I can even play
c5c 44 between before and so on playing
on them the beef I'll see 5c four is a
kind of a debatable decision definitely
because it yeah its weak on the dark
squares but I have some advantages of
course for it maybe start with this
rugby aid sorry route before and being
an idea you cannot easily play Bishop d3
or so i have c form i have c form I
thought I could have played rook before
actually it was interesting
okay well this is nothing to worry about
and all okay takes with the pawn so this
is a very solid structure if it takes
with the rook i mean i can't play Ouija
5v5 even just with this pawn however he
might get some play against e6 so i'm
not sure about that the pawn is big only
five anyway so route before Queen g5
it's not okay maybe I should do that
actually okay okay just for a moment if
I take their I rook takes on and then he
tries to block on c5 maybe this with
success I have look be five and then c5
hmm it also just play c5 right away but
okay that shouldn't really be an issue
can also do this preparing c5 c6 I
Brooke a be eight and b3 I don't know
and then screen a3 and things nine and I
don't think that is too great ok so I'm
going to push that and then I'm a porn
app right this is one point and a nice
game I have Brooke a be eight and see
for coming look a v8
yeah that looks nice right he's got them
problems defending here the question is
maybe you have six as an idea i wonder
if i should play hmm just back here now
this let's just cover you six so that i
can actually move the Queen okay so what
is he doing work f4 h4 maybe I don't
know this is kind of belonging in this
anyway let's push the a pawn yeah real
good sure but I have aged six so it's
not really a really an issue
okay so i still have is six covered if
you get get here for Queenie one I can
maybe play a three and go to a two it's
not I don't see a very I can take you
five I can take you 5 21 take c5 if he
goes something like a three it's not so
easy here actually to to cover
everything yeah it covered cavity one
cannot cannot play a three I can play D
forever and time learning yeah probably
see three years main threat okay I
cannot take unfortunately or something
there is no it's not so not so far away
from working ok we just go back here and
threaten c3 looks good after c3 ok it's
frightening Queen f7 f8 with mate that
is no it's no made I'm covering f8 so
wait don't don't need to rush things I
mean I don't need to play the king or
whatever or h6 FFA projector
quite resigned not even a check now not
new tricks right no tricks yeah wow that
was that was a very tricky situation
here actually I think if I have pretty
much saved me this um I thought it was
an interesting opening sequence I took
with the deep on ember the beep on so
that should be ok he went here and this
is an interesting moment here I'm
thinking g5 should be right maybe it
wasn't I don't know g5 and long castles
and now it's kind of difficult if Bishop
see three Queens III hmm yeah that that
wasn't really great right and if i go
here he will take with the night and
this is definitely yeah okay for white
that was thinking actually i should
should play for an edge here with this
we keep on just tactically amenia I'm I
was thinking maybe that's what really
not the case stockfish is just giving me
a slight edge with this then rupee aid
but that I cannot believe I mean I
really want to win this pawn if I'm not
willing the bond it's kind of it's kind
of weird an interesting question is this
is actually given by the engine because
here I'm very quick with Rupert II am
there is some point to that yeah this is
opening this opening Fei Jie some is
tricky a very interesting idea here with
Queenie 79 f6 is maybe the best move but
Queenie 7 often irritates people very
much it's not easy to to reply to that
to the attack on the e4 pawn and yeah
but it is not clear this is really not
clear at all yeah and here we're Queens
III was just wrong let's yeah it's a
simple move but it's just wrong you kind
of expect Bishop takes to have the
bishop on the long diagonal
Kim this is just stronger and the text
on c6 yeah I have to Castle it's no no
use be Bishop d7 or something it's just
that's just passive and I can take for
Rukia 1m ok yeah I have to cancel that
that's clear anyway yeah but now now we
need to improve for white if I've is
definitely giving it away I mean an
advantage I think but what should we do
maybe I was a bit too negative here the
computer is just giving white 0.4 so I
mean an advantage but nothing nothing
great I mean this this I didn't hear
very much I thought I can go here and
then take with an eye that should be ok
I mean are pretty well-developed it's
not that I'm behind them but takes maybe
a Knight takes Queen c6 I looks fishy
for black so pawn takes pawn takes and
then let's say something like that
intending to possibly take
yeah that is definitely better for what
I'm a bit surprised actually that when
the computer is giving stockfish gives
this and gives white 0.3 jam jam maybe I
mean I actually dislike my position
quite a bit here I'm a bit surprised
that stock pressures just giving this
low and evaluation now if you look at
this I mean this is a pretty bad
structure to a a and H porn is isolated
I mean I've if we go with this pawn
Island system yeah I have I have at
least one two three four four pawns and
this is the d5 c7 thing is not exactly
ideal so it's a really bad structure
what i have is i have decent central
control maybe this is kind of saving me
like I get this this end I'm sorry a
five now maybe but white is definitely
better and this is this already okay I
think this is already okay i really i
thought you would take maybe but i can
take F to right and I can do this take F
2 yeah so this and now i'm already okay
definitely i have this c5 idea and my
central control is just it's just worth
something now this is kind of weird that
you went for that no I'm in really good
shape five oh I'm sorry just go we
should be seven of course that was very
simple yeah this happens when you really
don't look at at the position I mean if
you don't really look what candidate
moves you have I'm just totally
violating this because I just said to
myself okay I'm going to take I was just
what it was in the in the game and this
and I'm just better right which is true
black is pretty clearly better even but
in the other line I just win apiece so
it's over and this is still a game of
course
that was very stupid there and now this
is our played well getting in c 5 yeah
here black is essentially winning I just
have to make sure that I'm not not
blundering stuff but I think I didn't
allow anything substantial yeah it was
good that hear that f8 was protected so
I didn't I mean this is winning but I
don't need to spend time on that I can
just play c3 and get my own attack
immediately yeah I hope you like this
thanks for watching